Each person's genome has about three million
single nucleotide variations, as well as many
other types of genetic variations. How do we
predict the function of these genetic variations?
On May 14th 2013, movie star Angelina Jolie
revealed that she has a mutation in her BRCA1 gene
and that her mother died early from breast cancer.
To reduce her own risk of getting breast cancer,
she made the drastic decision to have
both of her breasts surgically removed.
This revelation sent shock
waves all over the world.
Many people wondered and argued
whether she had made the right choice.
The core of Angelina Jolie's decision touches
upon an important bioinformatics question.
Given that she has a genetic mutation in BRCA1,
what is the conditional probability that she will
develop breast cancer? Even with her mutation,
there is a chance that she may be cancer free.
These two probabilities add up to one.
Before we talk about how to calculate these
numbers, let's first look at where our genetic
variations come from. We all know that we inherit
genetic variations from our parents. If our mother
carries a particular mutation allele, there is 50%
chance that we may inherit it from her. Each of
us also have over 70 de novo single-nucleotide
mutations that neither of our parents have.
Many severe childhood neurological disorders
such as Rett syndrome are caused by de novo
mutations that disrupted critical genes.
Each of us also has somatic mutations, that
are accumulated during cell divisions. An
extreme example of this is cancer, where somatic
mutations cause cells to grow uncontrollably.
There are many types of genetic variations in
the human genome. Different genetic variations
may have very different effects on
the genome and on the phenotype.
The most severe is chromosomal aneuploidy,
meaning that a person has one or more copies
of actual chromosomes or missing chromosomes.
The best known example is Down Syndrome, which
is caused by three copies of chromosome 21 or
Trisomy 21 which almost always have been de novo.
We never hear about Trisomy 1 or Trisomy
2 in humans, because these chromosomes are
so large and contain so many genes that having
abnormal copies of them is embryonically lethal.
Another type of microscopic or submicroscopic
genetic variation in the human genome is
structural variations. They include deletions,
duplications, inversion, insertions and
translocation. Deletion is a type of mutation
involving the loss of genetic material.
Insertion is a type of mutation involving the
addition of genetic material. Many mobile elements
are inserted in each of our genomes. A novel
sequence, such as virus genomes are sometimes
inserted into our genome. There are 2 types
of genetic duplications. Tandem duplications
happen where a segment of a chromosome is
duplicated right next to the original copy.
Interspersed duplications happen where a segment
of the chromosome is duplicated to somewhere else
on the genome. Deletions and duplications are
often called copy number variations or CNVs.
Finally, two other types of genetic structural
variation that cause disruptions of the genome
but not genomic balance include inversions
where a segment of a chromosome is inverted.
And translocations where a segment of a chromosome
is moved to somewhere else on the genome.
Short insertions and deletions of one or a few,
up to a thousand or several thousands nucleotides,
sometimes called indels. Indels may
happen in intergenic or intronic regions,
or they may happen within protein coding
regions. Within protein coding regions,
if an indel involves three or
multiplicity of three nucleotides,
it will only add or delete one or several codons
without causing a frameshift. Otherwise, it may
cause a frameshift that may result in a complete
changed of the amino acid sequence. Often it
would also cause a premature stop codon. The new
protein may not be stable enough to exist at all.
At a smaller scale, but with much higher
frequency, there are single nucleotide variations.
On average, in a person's genome, there is about 3
million SNVs, roughly equivalent to 1 SNV in every
1,000 nucleotides. SNVs that are known to affect
functions and phenotypes the most are located in
the promoter regions or protein coding regions
of genes. Variations in UTR and intronic regions
sometimes also affect function. Most variants
are located in intergenic regions between genes.
Some of them fall in non-coding RNA
that are transcribed but not translated.
SNVs within coding regions tend to have larger
effects than other variations and those have been
studied the most. In the more severe cases, SNV
can cause a premature stop codon that terminates
a protein early. In this example shown, the
cytosine nucleotide is changed to thymine.
As a result, the codon CUG that used
to encode amino acid of glutamine,
now it becomes TAG which is a stop codon
resulting in premature termination of the protein.
This SNV is called a nonsense mutation. Because
a nonsense SNV causes premature termination of a
protein, it is usually predicted to be damaging,
even though there are exceptions where paralogous
proteins or alternative pathways can
compensate for the loss of a protein.
In the second example, the adenine
nucleotide is changed to cytosine.
As a result, the codon CAT that used to encode
the amino acid histidine now it becomes CCT
which encodes proline. This SNV is called a
non-synonymous or missense SNV. Because the
codons are degenerative, many SNVs do not cause
amino acid changes. They are called synonymous,
or same sense or silent SNVs. Some SNVs at or
near splice injunctions may affect splicing.
And finally, some SNVs change a stop codon to
a codon encoding amino acid, resulting in a
lessening of the protein which may have altered
or disrupted stability, structure and function.
Synonymous, intronic, and intergenic variations
are often ignored. However, according to GWAS
studies, 88% of trait-associated variations of
weak effect are non-coding. Although, individually
their functional effects may not be as obvious,
because these regions are so large, their total
effects cannot be neglected, especially, a mild
traits. However, they remain under-studied,
and better methods are still needed.
Most research so far had focused on missense SNVs.
A big reason is because known deleterious
mutations are enriched in missense mutations.
About 50% of all known mutations of
Mendelian disorders are missense mutations.
However, it is important to note that
there might be ascertainment biases
because an important discovery tends to
attract more research in the same direction.
However, not all missense
SNVs cause phenotypic changes.
For instance, BRCA1 was the first
gene associated with breast cancer
in 1990 based on linkage analysis of large
pedigrees of early onset familial breast cancer.
BRCA1 has a total of 238 known missense
mutations, 163 are present only in patients,
62 are present only in healthy persons, and
13 in both patients and healthy persons.
Furthermore, even missense variations
seen only in patients are not all causal.
If we look more broadly, analysis of the whole
genomes of over 1,000 healthy individuals in the
1,000 Genome Project revealed that, on average,
a healthy individual carries over 3 million SNPs,
over 361,000 indels, almost 16,000
deletions, over 400 duplications,
and almost 5,000 mobile element insertions.
Within protein-coding regions, on average,
a healthy individual carries large division
that disrupt about 150 genes over 1,000
stop coding SNPs, 77 stop losses, over 900 small
frameshift indels, over 700 small in-frame indels,
nearly 70,000 non-synonymous SNPs and 60,000
synonymous SNPs. So, the questions are,
what features differentiate disease-causing
variants from neutral ones? How can we predict
whether a variation is disease-causing? Unlike
sequence alignment and sequence database search,
the questions here remain largely unsolved. And
there's still lots of active researches going on.